déjà première révélation de la soirée
jean yanne ne s'appelle pas jorian
jorian s'appelle jean gougy vous aviez a
fait changer mais pendant mon enfance il
ya eu beaucoup de d'utilisation un peu
annexes et décalé dray et pourquoi yan
cimon prénom yann parce que je suis
d'origine bretonne gouhier ça veut dire
petit marrant que c'est joli tout ça
alors vous dites que vous êtes né donc
j'étais en 33 on peut le dire et vous
dites alors quand on est en train de
prononcer tout farcir
il y avait d'abord tous les ans en
examen parce qu'elle cherche il s'était
en deux parties le diplôme d'etudes
primaires deux parties le brevet
élémentaire le pcf 2 pc en de parricide
on appelait les classes nouvelles c'est
dire que jusqu'à la guerre de bain dont
les cantons est né en 33 ans n'a cepe
temps à la guerre à ce qu'on commence à
aller vraiment de mon collège à 10 ans
aux gens et là c'était les classes
nouvelles après la guerre dont on
essayait tout en deux parties voilà donc
une petite touche artichauts versée en
deux parties et le service militaire
faut dire qu'à l'époque c'était 28 mois
quand même à 32 32
il ya de la prison là dedans
un placard ya qu il ya eu un petit peu
de pression mais pas longtemps parce que
comme c'était la guerre d'algérie on
m'avait mis en prison à la caserne du pl
est et la prison était un peu dans mon
sous-sol et moi je me trompe je me
prends des eaux soupirail je disais je
suis arabe bertomeu tort que la coupe et
la marche alors les gens aimaient
protester les agricultures et les arabes
non mais l'allemand s'est excusé bientôt
groupe bien alors votre père était
ébéniste et ensuite lithographe abord
l'idée heureusement que vous êtes là
comme ça se fait corriger mais de niche
mais il faisait des lithos de benjamin
rabier ça c'est vrai oui c'est vrai mais
justement où bonne question mais à
jeanne arabe il c'est le type qui a gazé
six heures hb qu'ils réclament c'est
paris c'est vrai oui votre mère était
couturière
oui chez madeleine vionnet et chez
lanvin
oui juste vous allez au lycée shuttle
vient collège sur vos lycées chaptal
c'est bien voir si koné savic l'école de
journalisme vous avez été virés ou cette
partie non je suis j'ai pas été jusqu'à
la fin j'ai pas été viré je suis pas
parti c'est à dire que les deux
premières années c'était l'école normale
et à partir de la troisième année
c'était les techniques de la presse donc
là ça m'embêtait un peu l'imprimerie
l'école estienne tout seul servier vient
de journaliste n'est pas un meneur et
alors là après la guerre vous rencontrez
quelqu'un qui s'appelle bob du parc à
saint germain il s'appelle bob du pack
de marsoui du gab et de toy non tarifée
d'encre je fais passer le pas sur la
fiche pour tous marqués non ce qui est
génial c'est que là vous faites vous
commencez à faire du cabaret et vous
faites un cabaret de rivoli d'histoire
insensé qui s'appelle l'académie dès 20
heures expliqué nous parce que là il y
avait des gens qui venaient
les cartes non c'était il y avait un
cabaret qui était une rue de rivoli qui
doit s'appeler le slow club maintenant
qui est au 2eme une affiche au deuxième
étage en tout seul et le pâton ils
appâtent one avait trouvé un truc c'est
que c'est qu'il y avait des cars qui
faisait la tournée des grands ducs à
paris dans le hall i do à pigalle et il
fallait une cave saint germain des prés
mais c'était très dur de se garer à
saint-germain-des-prés c'était beaucoup
plus facile de se garer à rue de rivoli
et comme les touristes n'y voyait que du
feu
les cars arrivaient à saint germain des
prés et nous on avait fait un spectacle
qui était qu'ils n'avaient pas de début
qu'ils n'avaient pas de fin ça n'avait
pas d'importance puisque quand le car
arrive et en os ont sonné les types
descendait le spectacle était commencée
et au bout de quelques temps le guide
leur disais bon bah c'est terminé pour
partir et il partait avant que ça finit
et alors il fallait vraiment accrédités
saint germain dit pas ce que vous en
faites vous jouiez le temps oui pendant
qu'elle était restée telle après direct
dix ans dans le dos et alors on avait en
nous alliant un moment mais il faut
quand même que ce soit plus saint
germain des prés alors on a trouvé un
mec qui ressemblait à ça on l'a mis dans
un coin avec un bloc il l'écrivait
les rues basses assez jean paul sartre a
fait josiane entre dans le cheminement
gage et autres abonnés par jacques
canetti après un service militaire est
là pour connaître vous avez une bonne
gage de ses charges et du costume sous
lion c'est vrai ça c'est pas vrai c'est
un fume c'est pas vrai le mec qui fait
du fish c'est moi qui fais mes fils et
moi c'est moi qui fais mais visiblement
vous avez dû me déclarer vous avez vu
les gars et un jour je vous étiez s'est
torché que j'avais dû le dire le service
militaire je faisais quand j'étais jeune
j'ai fait mon service militaire dont
pour la première partie de sa base
militaire au service historique de
l'armée
oui mais quand on est au service
historique de l'armée on n'écrit pas
forcément l'histoire des jupons et
l'histoire du vêtement souvient qu'il
n'était pas fou de l'armée non j'étais
au service torride armée ou aux classes
est toutes les choses qui concerne l
armée et toutes les shows militaire une
gâche pas compris pas mal ça vous
permettait de continuer à vous occuper
de vos activités en isoler les loisirs
bon alors là c'est l'époque des cabarets
alors se dit plus rien à personne
aujourd'hui les cabarets l'amiral club
55 des trucs plus personne ne sait ce
que c est alors à l'époque vous faites
vous rencontrer jacques martin ont fait
cette émission mythique qui s'appelle un
égal 3 on va voir d'ailleurs un sketch
que je vais dire avant tu sais que j'ai
reçu un email dans les nommer laurent
picone qui est un français qui habitent
en hollande et qui me dit ma femme et
moi on a décidé de faire un enfant
et de l'appeler serge et quand l'enfant
sera né en lui offrira un chien et on
l'appellera manier tour
tu verras ce que tu voudras fredo mais
dans cette année gros de beethoven et
ben on sent encore vachement l'affluence
de mozart pour dire que c'est la période
charnière de l'évolution beethovénienne
je suis d'accord avec toi mais c'est
plus sensible dans la légende dans la
déliant fin c'est en filigrane dans le
fait c'est sa deuxième manière avait
sauvé lé c'est du bac et ceux du pass
producteurs souhaitent
ces petits fous là
c'est françois son billet bah ouais ça
vraiment prendre un peu tu reconnais pas
la taille c'est adrian flambard combien
ils jouent plus délié dans les aigus
samedi dernier j'ai novembre mais les
mots massaloux des invalides pour
entendre du projet bien du froid et que
je viens du fric
quant à lui qu'il a une bonne
persistance rythme et doit les tuer
sincèrement il joue bien mais il sait
pas servir de la deuxième gueule devant
sa dépouille à l'enregistrer sont au
dessus mais quand il un bon instrument
comment qu'il défend je vais lire
impliqués
et c'est qu'il est
les ibères jeu serait chouette tu sais
ce que c'est tu ferais tu mounir est un
peu tôt
ouais je suis le roseau dressé dans le
désert de la chrétienté
je suis là triste aux fleurs flétrissent
mlle pas défaillant je suis la colombe
qui chante dans la chapelle du créateur
je suis le cri d'amour de l'occident
venta ils ont fait 10 de faire mais j'ai
choisi le passage le plus mince ou que
tu arrêteras ce que voit plus clair à
lui-même
georges les routiers mais aussi brian
ickler ya aussi permis de conduire qui
est très connu qui est en latin et que
tout le monde connaît le permis de
conduire est alors en 64 il ya eu un
sketch relancer une histoire terrible
c'est un sketch tv napoléon qui faisait
une course cycliste avec ses généraux un
c'est celui qui vous a fait virer
celui-là ou non non non celui qui nous a
fait virer non non non celui qui nous a
fait virer c'est une science qui cheese
passé dans une église et où moi je
t'entends de mettre des fleurs sur
l'autel et puis m'a fait rentrer en moto
et un rosier saisir ses moyens physiques
lorec et martin me déshabillait et il me
fallait du gringue est en baisse c'est
ma salopette s'agit là ça a été dur et
puis un autre truc aussi au chevet
schweitzer et où je viens poupoule alors
là c'est un des plus étonnants
aujourd'hui alors voilà donc ça donc moi
ça a été pour moi fondateur et je pense
que beaucoup de gens aussi et en 65 pour
rencontrer claude chabrol et vous faites
des films très important en fait le
boucher la ligne de démarcation que la
bête meure en fonction des films très
important godard ou fait week end il a
un fils me suis très important et puis
après ça s'est un petit peu gâté mais
vous dites tout le monde croit que j'ai
joué des navets qui après les bons films
en fait vous allez commencer par les
bons films où j'ai commencé à faire des
bonds si j'ai fait les navets après
ouais c'est ça mais j'ai fait les navets
avec une certaine volupté
c'est pas parce que ma pas engagés dans
des banques en est la preuve
je trouvais ça bien de faire des films
séries qui après les navettes a refait
des bons chine je l'avais azumi a sans
arrêt à cette époque là les
les comiques faisait très peu de temps
dans les films d'harry cole faisait une
demi-journée dans nos frais et ça
suffisait pas ce que ea les gens allez
le voir il entendait hour guerra cocagne
où les gens étaient ravis
alors tous les tous les gens qui
faisaient des films voulait avoir au
moins une demi-journée ou une journée
d'al qods et moi j'étais avec francis
blanche et nous on nous mettait tout le
temps dans le fond il y avait des scènes
qui se passait dans les films n'importe
n'importe où et nous on parlait on
faisait les métèques on était au bar et
on parlait et alors le metteur en scène
des alevis parlé entre vous alors on
parlait alors bon quand on savait plus
quoi dire on avait un code et on disait
je suis catholique comme vous c'était le
principe général je suis fatigué hier
j'ai mangé traque mondiale ne fait pas
un pli scellé
et puis je suis rentré tard la maison et
puis moi je vais vous dire je suis
catholique comme vous alors je savais
qu'il irai plus rien espérer que
j'enchaîne alors jeu mais qu'est-ce que
vous rapportez de plaisanterie facile
moi aussi je jusqu'à ce que j'en ai
juste onze plus rien et moi aussi je
suis catholique comme le temps de re de
chercher dans les antilles à la c1 ce
qu'on trouvera pas parce qu'évidemment
ça a été foutu un poubelle mais c'est la
même chose s'il ya six à huit prises et
a8 prizee fermé jamais est ce que vous
croyez que c'est un grand acteur s
couperet que c'est un grand acteur parce
que vous prenez ça par dessus la jambe
non non pas du tout j'ai d'abord jeu
je devrais pas dire surtout à la
télévision française devant des
milliards de gens dans le monde qui
parle français croyait pas si bien dire
je suis un grand acteur jeudi c'est le
mot exact merci je remercie beaucoup
je longe dit simplement je suis un
acteur plausible civière je n'ai jamais
fait de choses qui me paraissent pas
plausible un bon si on me demande de
faire un vétérinaire
je connais des vétérinaires qu'on ma
tête mon allure montre ouvertement je
préfère les terrines r si on me demande
de faire un camion jusqu'en les
camionneurs como allure donc
emportements je peux conduire un camion
si on me demande de faire un pianiste
romantique avec george sand là je fais
pas c'est je peux pas faire les lions
oui alors quand vous avez le prix à
cannes le prix d'interprétation pour pia
là pour nous n'oublierons pas ensemble
une remarquable vous alors tout le monde
vous admire tout le monde chante vos
louanges et vous vous dites montre il
suffisait que je baisse les yeux pour
arrière triste jeu baisser les yeux pour
regarder mon texte en fait l'essai
pense-bête partout dans la voiture et
tout le monde crier au génie
oui mais je peux plus le faire parce que
je vois plus clair alors avant je
pouvais baisser les yeux lui remet en
texte offre au cul et on disait il est
triste maintenant si je dis tu sais j'ai
de la peine y'a un mec et les goûts
il ya un mec était comme mousse était
chancelier adenauer
parce que lui c'est pareil vous dites on
a toujours cru qu'ils étaient vachement
sérieux alléno mère avait une blessure à
l'arrière était chancelier allemand
après la guerre c'est le premier
chancelier allemand alors il a eu une
blessure de guerre qui lui a coupé les
zygomatiques et les zygomatiques y sont
de chaque côté du stage je vois comment
il a pu prendre un éclat d'obus double
qui lui a coupé les deux mais ils
n'auraient pas ils pouvaient pas faire
autrement
il ya un mec qui fait ça mieux que moi
dans le
là dans la lecture des des textes de ces
brando vrais oiseaux ils touchent pas
une bille malika n'est jamais sans texte
quand il a fait après call if you know
il devait sortir d'une grotte et on
pouvait la scène était filmée d'un
bateau qui était sur la rivière donc on
pouvait promettre un prompteur on
pouvait pas mettre quelque chose pour
qu'ils lisent
alors on a dû mettre son texte de
l'autre côté de la rivière il a salué un
texte de 20 mètres de haut au classement
un panneau gigantesque maison écrit son
texte à la bombe et vous vous dites plus
je souris plus super triste je défends
vous dise souris sourit c'est vrai voilà
tout le temps envie de vous dire
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas l'air content
souriez souriez pour voir quand vous
dites a finalement que le tracteur bah
oui c'est comme un cordonnier qui a
appris à réparer des chaussures depuis
l'âge de 19 ans et lui connaît bien son
métier on lui demande pas d'être
passionné quoi on a le sentiment vous
faites ça comme ça vous faites très très
bien mais avec une espèce de distance je
crois que c'est le principe même du
du bon travail c'est à dire que on n'a
jamais où il ya pas de ce quart de la
plomberie
non on comprenait il n'y a pas de ya pas
de gens qui se félicite corporatives
mans à longueur de journée comme nous
bon je sais que ça nous a beaucoup
touchés d'avoir le 7 d'or puisque j'ai
vu des larmes couler sur vos joues mais
bon vous vous rendez compte qu'il y
avait les sept d'heures de la pâtisserie
il essaie de ces câbles et camionneurs
ce serait comme les routiers fébrile
viendrai pleurer
et alors là bon continuer la vie de jean
yanne qui est passionnante
alors au delà de cette mélodie qu'on
connaît tous il faut savoir que tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil et est le premier film anti pub
anti société de consommation anti radios
commerciales
les mecs il nous fait de beigbeder des
années avec dédé des années 60
absolument se dire que les mecs ils
bouffaient enfin vous avez vu le film
rend les mecs film culte il bouffe et
les conserves il s'est couvert de
boutons dans la radio le mâle 20 ouais
alors aujourd'hui un mouvement vous
savez ça qui s'appelle les casseurs de
pub vous connaissez les casseurs de pub
un nom
les casseurs de pub c'est un mouvement
de résistance à l'agression publicitaire
iad journée sans un char et aujourd'hui
c'était la journée de 25 ans aujourd'hui
c'était la journée sans achat
aujourd'hui c'était ma oui je voulais
mettre pour acheter aujourd'hui ils ont
fait un acte criminel parce que c'était
aujourd'hui la journée sans achat est il
l'un d'eux aurait dû sauver l'un composé
des buts
ils ont été voir leurs mômes en même
temps et donc la publicité il dit ça
ramène l'être humain au rang de produit
10 la pub bestial is la pub c'est du
totalitarisme soft vous pensez ça aussi
nom de temps en temps la pub est d'abord
rigologue c'est vrai des trains marrante
et puis ça montre simplement qu'il ya
des gens qui ont des idées de temps en
temps c'est irritant
parce que l'on ment et là on le sait
comment et c'est embêtant parce que la
plupart du temps on ment pour les
produits pas chers d'encombrants aux
petites gens
mais si le mec il dit me fais de la
publicité pour une robe du soir à 80
mille balles et qui dit oh regardez
comme je serai une princesse j'avais une
parcelle de broder bon bah ça va venir
mais c'est surtout les petits produits
pour les petites les petites choses qui
risque d'avoir les grands mères il
chassait pas ça c'est pas très bien cela
dit la pub ça permet à plein de gens de
faire le ce qui n'existe plus maintenant
c'est le court métrage
ouais parce que dans le cinéma ya plus
beaucoup de courts métrages ont peur
continue ballon car la pub c'est une
bonne école parce qu'il faut et efficace
croyez vous encore qu'une croissance
infinie est possible sur une planète où
les ressources sont limitées
le samedi 25 novembre c'est la journée
sans achat alors faites un geste pour la
terre
arrêtez d'acheter voilà aujourd'hui
relate journal donc casseurs de plus ça
existe les états unis s'appelle
adbusters
il ya tout un mouvement comme ça de
citoyens contre la pub aussi une journée
sans pognon aussi vrai ça serait drôle
alors mais vous êtes quand même très
branché pognon non on a la pression chez
porcher poney on a l'impression quand
même que vous avez comme ça toute votre
vie
j'avais un peu couru après l'argent
regardes et tu dis que tu es catholique
comme les non bien sûr que je suis moche
et pognon et c'est comme laisser comme
les rôles c'est vrai on dit par exemple
moi j'ai dit ça plusieurs fois je dis je
on reçoit sur son scénario on me dit
vous serez en costume de lin blanc sur
une plage avec une très belle jeune
fille qui va vous servir des pompes et
puis un mec qui va vous éventé derrière
et vous allez poser votre main d'un sac
de loukoums et l'autre main sur un bon
c'est plus un verbe que d'aller tourner
germinal dans le
dans les corps donc mais pas forcément
les plus à même de gagner de l'argent
que pas en avoir que c'était plus à
perdre dans des beaux endroits que dans
des endroits pour mieux c'est plus
agréable de bien manger que manger de la
merde et apache propos de reparler d'une
compagnie aérienne
alors vous êtes vous êtes un peu ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un bon mot
vous excuser un bobo c'est un bourgeois
bohème ça c'est des gens qui ont des
idées de gauche et qui est le gain de
confort de droite
ouais bah oui 6 non mais j'ai pas dis
débauche ah bon armand vous disiez que
vous aviez des idées de gauche il avait
des idées un peu gauche mais parce
qu'avant avons quand même il disait j'ai
dès maintenant
non c'est dire qu'à une certaine époque
les idées de gauche c'était facile à
déterminer
jusqu'à maintenant les 10 et du gauche
quelle différence il ya entre didier de
gauche et lille sont tous font
l'économie de marché mais vint donc et
surtout sur la mondialisation
alors vous êtes un jeune papa quel âge
il à votre enfant de neuf ans neuf ans
vous avez changé d'avis depuis les
années soixante dix mois j'ai retrouvé
une déclaration sur les enfants étaient
terribles les enfants je les déteste
réussir un mariage c'est difficile mais
si on rate ça peut s'arranger un enfant
raté ça ne s'arrange jamais si j'en
avais eu j'aurais pas la patience de
m'en occuper et si des fois j'avais la
patience je lui inculque aurait que des
notions qui ferait lui est malheureux
que ça j'en ai eu un qui va maintenant
est grand il m'en suis pas occupé
beaucoup ray occupe maintenant n'aurions
sauf les enfants quand on est vieux
d'abord parce qu'on y en a pas longtemps
c'est en tant que jeune quentin besoin
vivent bien séparées et embêté par des
mots mais c'est quand on est vieux on a
le temps de s'en occuper
vas-y on pouponne c'est bien vous avez
une vraie philosophie des ducs ont fait
dites moi vous pensez quoi jean yanne de
jean pierre bacri parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu votre
successeur dans la non il a un côté de
lui comme vous voyez là c'est espèce de
l'humour que vous mais en tous les cas
il fait de ce culte est comme ça
complètement oui bah oui oui le plus il
entre en bourse mal léché oui mais c'est
ça ouais si vous en faites votre grand
plaisir c'est de bouffer après le tout
seul dans la cuisine
ça dépend un peu beauf et un poil avec
quelqu'un d'autre je dis ici on lui
arrive d'être à l'ours bien léché aussi
c'est vrai que là mais la solitude n'est
ce pas est un truc qui m'a toujours
épaté quand j'ai vu les bons tacles il
ya des gens malheureux et qui sont
encore plus malheureux parce qu'ils sont
seuls mais la solitude ne m'a jamais
paru est une chose dramatique parce
qu'on est tellement bien quand on est
tout seul vous il ya juste le perroquet
qui vous pris fin peu l'épaule le
perroquet maintenant il va bien parce
qu'il a une copine
ils nous emmerdent moi alors